much and we also have him like carlson
with us here just to give a quick
reaction on um
not the chess situation as much but the
match situation uh obviously you must be
very happy now
well i'd like uh them to finish this
game because now magnus has spent like
six minutes on this move so obviously
there are things to calculate still
but of course
we have talked about how uh
game six was very important game eight
was very important but this is at least
as important probably
in with regard to the much outcome
so i'm just thinking emotionally you
must be a very very proud
dad is it possible for you at all as a
chess fan to feel a little bit sorry for
jan here
well if banks wins this game yeah maybe
yeah but
i still like mines to win the game
frankly yeah
well thank you very much so there you
have it the empathy has not turned off
completely even though henrik is of
course a very proud dad
yeah and
of course he is correct as well you know
magnus he has five minutes left for the
next five moves
it's getting slightly worrying um i
guess magnus is just debating whether to
go and capture a pawn with the black
knight if he can get away with it and he
grabs even more material he'll be
technically four points up on the board
um but he doesn't need to necessarily um
lawrence pointed out some very nice
night maneuvers that i think just kill
the game that should win
very quickly um but
if you see the most ambitious move
you've got to rule it out first and if
he sees no reason to rule out the black
knight taking the g3 pawn then he might
well play it and uh that knight actually
also has a root round to the b5 square
that you mentioned lawrence using some
checks and there he goes he does indeed
take the pawn so
greed in this situation looks pretty
it's good okay
well let's see what yonder pogba now
does he uh
like i would never take that pawn but
that's just me
no if you've got four minutes if you
don't have time to calculate then why
bother right but uh magnus he calculates
quickly and he spent what was it seven
minutes there or so um so he had enough
time to calculate that his knight still
is on a decent circuit and it can get
round back to stop that white a pawn
that's running
uh
napoli actually meanwhile
he was surprised
yeah or bluffing it's a bluff you think
it's a bluff yeah maybe he just ruled it
out like we did kind of just
automatically just thinking oh there's
no reason to grab that form black loses
a bit of time with the knight
but uh after a bit of calculation i
think he'll realize that actually
it's just a decent move and now black
can win in several ways black actually
has a poor majority on that king's side
so uh just to illustrate like a
variation here so let's say yam pushes
pawn to a7 okay
rub two a8 only move
and now let's say rook to a6 which i
think is his idea to threaten knight a4
knight to b6 to go after this rook in
the corner yeah it takes a while now 92
check
important that we have that check king
f2
knight d4
okay let's go just in case anything you
know
sorry and yeah actually this even stops
knight a4 doesn't it so this square's
protected by the black knight and
actually he goes for the same idea as
yours but he starts in a different order
he pushed his knight backwards
gives up a pawn very nice move yeah
classy stuff
and uh okay the white pawn steps forward
okay magnus has got this all calculated
let's go back to the players because we
could well see and still still weird
that he went for this one because knight
b6 okay so white's actually maybe gonna
win a piece back but he's gonna be two
or three pawns down
unfortunately
so uh yeah you're right strange decision
maybe but i would have i would have done
92 94 but okay
when it's if it's winning it's if it's
winning it's winning it doesn't really
matter how how you do it
because he is a bishop and a porn up
the bishop comes to c6 yeah so the
bishop actually might i mean it's lived
a pretty sad life this whole game
black's bishop but it might just give
itself up for that really important
white pawn and then in the meantime
black's knight is going to go hunting
for pawns on the other flank and yeah i
envisaged this one being three pawns
down in an end game for yeah napoleon it
doesn't sound as bad as being a whole
bishop down but
still hopeless unfortunately
will he just uh reach more for you i
mean we have seen bigger shocks than the
bar move from for advantage to the other
side yeah
you know blunders
blunder but that tends to be in
positions with queens on where there's
mutual attacks and it's a bit of a race
this one
simply not a race uh no counter play
really for white once the e7 pawn
disappears
and uh actually maybe we should just
quickly show this before another
actually makes this move just just to
show what we think is going to happen
white's pawn now cannot move forward
it's the square protected by the rook so
we're expecting the knight to
try and help this pawn promote and now
the bishop simply
uh wow moves to c6 stopping this well
not stopping this pawn from promoting
but if the pawn does promote now to a
queen black happily gives up the bishop
just to force the white knight offside
and meanwhile the black knight will
retreat and white has won the bishop
back but in the meantime if we count the
pawns it's three versus five
um a bit like the score right now in the
match
and uh yeah this pawn is doomed it's
isolated it's about to fall and once
that pawn falls
the rest of the pawns as well easy
targets it's gonna be three pawn
advantage just like it's gonna be a
three point advantage in the match for
magnus
yeah
i hope nothing else to do um this is the
only plan for white really
there's only one oh no there isn't sorry
oh yeah there is
i'll try rook b1 take my knight please
oh you want to come to the top of the
board that's very sneaky laurence
yeah
and whoops there it goes to b8 but yes
and i win actually right you win yeah i
don't think you do even if the bishop
drops back maybe black's better sorry
even black's better that uh
are you sure well maybe not maybe it's
not so english
anyway you definitely want to avoid this
if you're magnus carson so you won't
take this knight instead lawrence sorry
i got it i've got to show something okay
just go there just to illustrate the
hopelessness of yan's task in the
absolute best case scenario the best
case
in that position there kaya after bishop
takes a4 rook b8 even if i go rook takes
rook
allowing you to queen i'm not sure after
king h7 this position is losing for
black i put the knight on f5 and the
king on each g6 and i probably even have
a fortress yeah you put the knight there
you put the bishop in the center white
queen alone will not be able even that
doesn't look losing from black to my
eyes and that's if magnus went
completely insane which is just not
if you let white get a queen basically
even allowing white to get the queen i'm
not even sure that is it i'm curious if
that's a that's a question for another
but it's a big difference between a draw
and a loss free answer
but that is in the best case scenario
where
uh
yeah magnus forgets how to play chess
and ivanka you wanted to show how we
refute this movie coming to the top of
the board you just put the rook on the
promotion square
and uh
once the rook does come down to the
seventh eighth row then uh just uh rook
takes pawn yep again
giving up the bishop for that key pawn
and now once the black king moves yes
you actually give back some material
with uh black but at the very end you
should still be winning here it's only a
one point advantage about to be two but
still sufficient for magnus
um there might even be quicker ways
easier ways to win this game yeah but uh
yeah this is again
at the very least
for magnus he's gonna be two pawns up in
an ending i mean is there any ideas with
the rook coming down to the seventh row
try to do some action like that sorry
yeah um i don't think there's time white
tonight is hanging on the edge of the
board so there's no time to ah
pity
just
out of ideas
lots of ideas i think you'll play the
rook move i think that's the only chance
yeah why not rook to b1
and uh
actually yeah black and even for example
just move the king in that position
black has made that's such a nasty many
options yeah
um yeah it's very sad very sad to see it
like this he wants one final trick
though before move 40 while magnus only
has four minutes left so makes sense
exactly yeah magnus has two moves to
make in four minutes
i've seen
worse things happen stranger things
happen than a blunder on me 40. yep
and even just to calm himself down after
making that blunder realizing it
you know to resign immediately you're
probably going to be even more emotional
right for sure
and
okay he takes this horn with his knight
which is like the least
the least scary the least scary move
exactly black specially his idea is to
put his night on
i'm trying put his knight on the c7
square or yeah okay trying to combine i
know try to i know so if you the bishop
does come out his idea is just to slide
across uh with his rook to the b1 square
and then do the idea of putting the rook
on b8 yeah
maybe
it doesn't look too effective
unfortunately black for example could
just put the rook in the corner
everything's defended but yeah bishop c6
exactly rook b1 and rook a8 so magnus
will play one of two moves now he'll
either bring the black bishop out to
stop the white pawn promoting or he'll
block the pawn with his in fact rook a8
might be more precise that might put an
end to all of white's ideas
yeah i think that move pretty much wins
on the spot doesn't it yeah the black
rook just parking itself in the corner
and white needs four or five moves to
rearrange the pieces and create a threat
but uh i have to say i mean it's very
unlikely that uh magnus won't play one
of those two moves but if he doesn't
okay maybe two moves
i mean unfortunately they're pretty
obvious because you have to stop the
pawn promoting
you're not really gonna move your king
um
what would be a bigger blunder magnus
not playing one of these two moves or uh
jan earlier
that his bishop was trapped
oh no this would be this would be the
greatest blunder of all time oh wow i
mean in a world championship match it's
not even close i mean the bishop blunder
was horrendous but if magnus doesn't
play rook a or bishop c6
it's beyond
uh well it's there
definitely thinking about it though is
it so
there's only two moves disposition for
minus yeah everything else is uh blunder
yeah he might not even be losing
actually definitely not using a few yeah
he might even still be better no no he's
not better he's uh slightly slightly
worse but after king age 70s or worse
it's slightly worse really yeah i'll
take black bear all day
yeah we're talking about black
accidentally blundering his rook for
that white pawn that fired that formula
i mean he has to have yeah and then he
definitely finds a right move here minus
the rook blocks the pawn from promoting
yeah and that might be the final shot
one more move now to make before the
time control before both players get an
extra hour
and uh that will be the signal i think
for jan to throw in the towel yeah so he
makes would you like to move would you
resign in a world championship match
here or would you continue i would play
time with 40. i mean i'd see nothing
useful for what to do now for example i
might just move the white king attack
the black knight and if black moves it
then i go off to the relaxation room for
like 20 minutes come back and then
resign just to
keep my opponent at the board
yeah i think sportsmanship wise probably
you don't want to keep your opponent
waiting for you just resign right
well i mean do you do
well i i wouldn't be in this position i
would have resigned a few moves ago as
again so just keep all the energy
uh
[Music]
well actually maybe it was good for him
to play some moves just to get rid of
the nervous energy yeah it feels a
little bit like it right especially with
another game tomorrow it's nice to just
touch the pieces because one rest day uh
from my experience even just having one
rest day you can feel rusty afterwards
i can tell you there's a zone at least i
can tell you this tomorrow if magnus
opens one e4
jan will not play one e5 yeah he will
not play king's porn opening no he's
playing petrol defense it's time for a
sicilian yeah or some french
yeah it's time to one of those two yeah
it's not even not even a question and i
can guarantee magnus will open with this
king's pawn you know situations where
he's happy with the draw okay always
does it no question that's a that's a
tip for all my rivals in the prediction
magnus will push his kingspoon but i
don't know what will happen after
dejected look at look at his body
language just somebody who
he hasn't
come to terms yet with what's happened i
think he's not
it's like those moments in your life
where something unfortunately that
happens to us all of us happens and you
can't quite believe it he's in that
phase and
uh
are you impressed by his poker face
though i mean occasionally occasionally
it breaks but not really no because
because
unlike poker
we can see exactly
what's going on we can see the cards on
the table face up
and you can put the poker face on all
you like but uh
your opponent has a full house your
opponent's the greatest player in the
world of all time play
and everybody knows and yeah do you
again think it's no chess moves going
through his head right now everything
else basically
you can just see it there yeah i mean
there are no logical moves for white
them yeah maintain a chance
white's like far away from even kicking
away that black rook now he it just
looks like he's
just giving himself the courage to
resign and it was in the press
conference after a game
last game game eight of course he said
that he was sorry it was a heartbreaking
sentence from him that he was sorry for
the way he played the blunder he made in
that game
i have a feeling we might see a
repetition of that because yeah if
anything this blunder was far worse than
his blunder in the previous game in game
eight so
uh this was this is not even in the same
league as blunder that was a terrible
blunder but but the fact he's
apologizing to the fans uh to the
russian supporters out there maybe is i
mean he's very aware of how many people
are watching the momentous occasion it's
very aware of the pressure
and that seems to have got to him i saw
a great quote actually by gary kasparov
where he said the eternal paradox of
peak performance
is
learning while still carrying on as if
you appear invincible oh and uh it was i
thought that was quite nice yeah that's
exactly what janna ponnichi has to do he
has to learn from this
this last few games and then just carry
on
get to
get to game 10 with a smile on his face
and this belief that yes he can do it
and that will be an accomplishment right
yeah mentally we talked about the 1984
match karpov against casper and that's
one to draw inspiration from so
yeah definitely he should be listening
to the words of gary kasparov
wow
game nine is over a terrible blunder by
anna pomnyacci will they talk about
it apparently they will
yeah but i thought maybe i could connect
e7 i'm not sure at night
yeah between 65
yeah i'm sure
yeah well it looks like we're talking
like 94 or something
yeah
no i mean okay for a moment i just
thought this is like some huge advantage
but actually i'm team should be fine
[Music]
there is just no way i mean no it's just
being awesome because the phone only 466
is never an idea because of 165 yeah
[Music]